un feet avec Jul et ce serait possible
oui tu pourrais te passer de ton
téléphone pendant 24 heures non la
trentaine ça te fait peur oui tu es à
l'aise dans les montagnes russes oui ça
t'arrive de dire 95 oui
tu confirai ta chienne à Orelsan non
c'était pas chanteuse ce serait
psychologue oui tu aurais pu faire The
Voice ou la Star Academy non cerné c'est
le meilleur acteur de sa génération oui
il y a des featurings que tu regrettes
non tu as déjà oublié tes paroles
pendant un concert oui Bruxelles c'est
mieux que Paris oui tu écoutes du métal
non dans un monde parfait est-ce qu’on
ne mange plus de viande oui la Belgique
est-ce qu'elle aurait dû gagner à Coupe
du Monde 2018 oui 2020 c'était la pire
année pour toi non tu as déjà triché
lors d'un examen oui et dernière
question pour terminer est-ce qu'il y a
tes propres chansons dans tes playlist
non